dans l'actualité aussi cette hausse
spectaculaire des plaintes pour violence
physique en Indre-et-Loire plus 15% en
un an une augmentation préoccupante pour
le préfet Patrice laton Latron pardon
qui en a fait des Tao aujourd'hui mais
ce qui retient l'attention dans le
département c'est l'explosion des
violences sexuelles les explications
avec la Turquie
tu as la hausse tout comme au niveau
national une augmentation générale
modérée mais certains curseurs sortent
du lot exemple le nombre de plaintes
pour violence physique explose plus 15%
par rapport à l'année 2021 mais il y a
aussi une
augmentation de ces violences sexuelles
qui sont insupportables c'est un fait
extrêmement préoccupant qui concerne
l'ensemble de la société et et qui doit
faire qui fera l'objet d'une vigilance
d'une attention
soutenue des forces de l'ordre pour les
violences sexuelles on constate une
hausse de 28% du nombre de plaintes en
comparaison à 2021 un chiffre record est
inquiétant qui traduit une augmentation
objective de ces violences mais une
autre piste est aussi envisagée une
libération de la parole des victimes sur
des faits commis parfois des années plus
tôt on a aussi de plus en plus de de
gens qui viennent à plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années après les faits pour
les dénoncer donc c'est plutôt un signal
malgré la hausse plutôt un signal
intéressant ça montre aussi peut-être
que les gens ont moins peur de venir en
gendarmerie ou dans un commissariat de
police pour dénoncer les faits au niveau
national les plantes pour violence
sexuelles augmentent également mais
moins fortement qu'en Indre-et-Loire 11%
de plus par rapport à l'année précédente